hi thanks for coming I know we're
competing with
John
and Scott Hanselman so I'm very
gratified that you've decided to come to
see me instead and my co speakers my
name is John stoven I've come from
Sheffield I work for a company called
three squared and if you were to find me
on Twitter I'm at John stoven I'm just
going to do a very quick talk about
webassembly you've probably seen some
other talks about it while you're here
they seem to have been quite a few so I
will I will go through this I hope I've
got a slightly different angle on it to
other people so what is it well it's
this is the definition from the
webassembly website
it's webassembly abbreviated wasm is a
binary instruction format for stack
based virtual for a stack based virtual
machine so what's different from what we
have already woods binary it's not
source code unlike JavaScript it's a
stack based so no registers everything
pushes and pops off onto or off the
stack and it's a virtual machine that
runs in the browser sandbox so again
quoting from the website it's a portable
target for the compilation of high-level
languages its size and load time
efficient it runs in a memory safe
sandbox environment on the browser and
it also supports non-web embeddings so
HTML that way sorry okay I'm just seeing
if I can write I just see my notes right
lovely thank you so we've got HTML and
JavaScript why do we need this you know
what do we need this for one word
performance so we're using bigger and
bigger JavaScript frameworks angular
react we they need so so page loads are
getting bigger javascript it is
interpreting in the browser so it's not
as fast as it could be some applications
just need more performance one of the
things I'm interested in is audio
synthesis it's very hard to do anything
meaningful in a browser so anything we
can do to improve
client-side performance is a benefit
there's also an opportunity possibly to
take existing code base is written in
non JavaScript languages and run them in
the browser
so you're saying haven't we tried this
before yeah I can think of several times
when we've tried this before we decide
flash that was a never-ending security
bonfire you need to install a client you
need to make sure your version your
client but the client version is up to
date
lots of compatibility issues
we tried Java again Java in the browser
you need to say to install the the
runtime separately ActiveX only works on
Internet Explorer again another security
bonfire Google Native Client so Google
came up with an idea of having some
something like this but only it only
runs in chrome and again people said
there were security issues with it so
the latest attempt was a thing called
azzam JS has anybody come across as in
j/s nope so the idea behind Adam jas was
to take a small subject subset pardon me
of the JavaScript language that could be
effectively efficiently precompiled
almost and then run that in the browser
the idea was to use that as an output of
compilers from other languages
particularly C++ it it got some
acceptance it does give you a
performance boost but it still has
problems so coming off the back of that
as in J's idea we've come to webassembly
so what what's what's different about
webassembly compared to to the other
things that i've mentioned already well
for a start it's an open specification
it's sponsored by the w3c so unlike for
example
for Java or flash it doesn't have a
commercial owner it's built into the
browser it's a w3 specific w3c
specifications so you don't need a
plug-in you can just run it on any
modern browser because it's part of the
browser it gets updated with the browser
update cycle and all modern browsers
have very thorough update cycles it's
widely available on all modern browsers
it's built upon the existing as some Jas
work that was done so as MJS was also a
w3c standard and a lot of the stuff that
was done for that can be reused for for
web assembly because it's a bytecode
rather than JavaScript it's faster to
parse and it's smaller size the compiler
and also the runtime do static and
dynamic checks to make sure that you
don't do bad things with it and it
promises near native performance I've
put near native in quotes because it is
not it may be promising it but it's
nowhere near that yet there's there's
lots of reasons to believe that there
are things that vendors can do to make
to improve the performance but but they
they're not doing that yet so these are
other goals of the way of assembly
working group they wanted a portable
binary format that run on would run on
any browser pretty much they wanted to
do a minimum viable product which they
based on as MJS and then add more
features later if they got wider
acceptance they wanted to execute within
and integrate with the existing web
platforms so they wanted something that
would automatically work with everything
that we already have that's kind of
given but they also wanted to be able to
support other scenarios for example iot
devices shells data center servers put
mobile devices
and they also wanted two formats one is
strict byte code but they also want a
human readable one as well one of the
one of the motivations for that is that
if you're running web assembly in your
browser you don't really want to have to
look at individual byte code in the in
the debugger it would be nice to have
something it was a bit more readable
than that just so you can understand
what's going on
so how does this all work well the
initial idea was to take C and C++ as
their kind of base language and compile
that to bytecode there is a an extension
for the LLVM compiler which takes the
output of that compiler and converts it
to two webassembly bytecode this was
built on top of an earlier version of
inscription that would compile to Adam
Jaya so again they were leveraging their
existing experience 2000 Jas so once
you've once you've compiled your
bytecode you can load it into your your
browser with it with a single call in
the page and then you can use the sequel
and see wrap methods to call into
individual functions in the byte code
that you've loaded I don't really have
time to go into it in any great detail
but there's just a kind of idea of how
it all works I've got a very quick
example here of some C the compiled to
bytecode just so you can understand how
it works everybody likes a factorial so
we've got a nice recursive factorial
function here you can see that the whole
thing is stacked so we've got here the
binary representation and this is the
the human readable version it's very
close to assembly language just a quick
example of what's happening here first
of all we take so with that we have a
function that takes a single parameter
here that's stored in position zero on
our stack then we push another value 0
on to the stack do a comparison so
that's this N equals 0 here
if they're the same then we push one on
the stack and return so that we return
this value otherwise we finally get our
end again push our n value twice onto
the stack then push one so that's here
we have n minus one we do the
subtraction then we call our our we we
call zero which is returning to the top
of the stack again so calling ourselves
and then when that returns we multiply
by the N we stuck on here and then we
return so entirely stack based
reasonably understandable they are going
to extend this there's that there is a
planter to provide some sort of portable
program database structure so that you
can at least see your variable names and
rather than just using local references
which will help
so as of March 2017 the the community
queue community group announced that
they have support for Chrome Age Firefox
and WebKit which pretty much covers the
entire spectrum of all the current
browsers they might be a few but they're
fairly minor so we have tooling support
several languages now so as I said
earlier C and C++ we have the M
scripting back-end for for the LLVM
compiler JetBrains have a Kotlin
compiler that will compile Kotlin
directly to webassembly a billy rust has
a compiler too and if you went to see
any of the talks earlier in the
conference you'll know certainly know
that they're about blazer which is net
runtime running and in the browser and
as a f-sharp developer I'm quite keen to
also
a bolero which is the sim uses the same
same the same runtime but bill uses
f-sharp as a language instead so
problems well it's not going to solve
all of all the problems that we have
with you know that we have with current
web applications you don't know what
sort of resources you've got on the on
the client that you're using so you
might be running on a very tightly
constrained mobile device for example so
you and at the moment as far as I know
there is no way of validating what sort
of resources you have on the client so
that you can kind of scale performance
to match the other problem is that the
the blazer and bolero both use a mono
runtime which is compiled down to two
webassembly
so you've got one virtual machine
running inside another virtual machine
which is bound to have some sort of
performance impact although from what I
understand the plan is in the near
future to have a compiler that will
compile dotnet directly to web assembly
that believe the mono team are working
quite hard on that at the moment and
certainly there was a demonstration of
that earlier today
so the question should you use web
assembly in your next project before I
got here my answer was no having seen
the presentations I'm more likely to say
not yet I'm more impressed with what
I've seen here than I was previously
admittedly a lot of the stuff I've seen
here has been kind of promises of stuff
to come roll and actually release
release software at the moment but it's
do it so it's worth looking at you
probably want to use it if you're
thinking of writing a browser-based game
or if you need some some more more
performance out of the browser then you
can currently get with JavaScript
there are problems your your webassembly
code at the moment can't interact
directly with the Dom so you have to
call you have to call back to JavaScript
and then get your JavaScript to talk the
Dom which is a performance hit and you
need to be confident that the client
you're going to run it on is actually
capable of doing what you're asking it
to do
so that's a quick overview of what web
assembly is and just again as a as an
f-sharp user if there are any other
f-sharp users here do give Bolero a try
and if you don't go and learn F sharp
and then try them try bolero so thank
you I don't know if I've got time for
questions but if Y any questions nope
good right thank you
[Applause]